hey guys it's inca and in this video i
will only be eating orange foods
for 24 hours so i am back at it again
finally doing this orange foods
challenge and honestly
i do think that it might be the perfect
time of year
to be doing this there's actually quite
a bit of food that is
under this category of being orange i'm
thinking
pumpkins i'm taking butternut squash
i'm sure there's more actually as per
usual i will be only finding foods that
are naturally colored
orange something tells me i'll be eating
a good bit of pumpkin
but before we get started i just wanted
to share that this video is brought to
you by skillshare
as most of you know i love sharing new
discoveries and learnings with all of
you and a lot of you always ask me you
know how to develop basic cooking skills
how to take the best food photos well i
think skillshare is one of the best
resources out there for you to start
developing those skills they have
a huge variety of classes they're just
really awesome food photography one by
daniel krieger
and for myself i'm actually taking some
food illustration ones and it's been
pretty fun so far
best part is the first 1000 people to
click on the link in the description
box below we'll get a free trial of
skillshare premium membership so
definitely check that out and i really
encourage you all to give it a try
alright so with that being said let's
start shopping
[Music]
it looks super interesting
good morning everyone it is orange food
day
super excited to get started with
breakfast
and here is what i have you can see this
huge fruit platter here here we have
mango papaya
cantaloupe and carrots acerola puree
which i've been putting into my
smoothies pumpkin pancake mix pumpkin
puree
pumpkin pie spice pumpkin butter this is
another one of those like seasonal items
i was thinking for fruits because
there's so much going on here
i'm going to blend these up to make them
into a very orangey
smoothie but first i'm gonna get started
on
our pancake mix all right so i just
poured out the pancake mix and it turns
out that it really
isn't that orangey so what i'm thinking
is i'm gonna add a good bit of pumpkin
in here and also an egg yolk the
instructions actually ask for an egg
but i think adding an egg yolk maybe
even two
will make it you know the orange color
that i want
a generous scoop of pumpkin puree
so i've also added in a little bit of
oil the last thing i have to add into
this is actually some
water but and i don't know if this is
kind of crazy i'm actually going to try
and substitute some of that with orange
juice
look at this color it's definitely like
a thicker consistency and i think that
has to do with all the stuff that i put
in you know the pumpkin
and not really following the box
instructions i'm going to add a little
bit of this pumpkin spice now
it smells so good i'm just going to go
ahead
and scoop some on here all right so
that's pancake number one
so while i'm waiting for this to cook on
one side i'm gonna get
my smoothie going my carrots
cantaloupe papaya mango acerola which
has now
melted so hopefully it's gonna balance
out that sweetness
i'm also adding in some more orange
juice this is truly
the most orange of orange smoothies
let's go
oh my god all right
and that's it smoothie is done now back
to our pancakes
so i just flipped it and this is what it
looks like
it is definitely a little more brown
than anticipated so i'm gonna make
another one and make sure that the sides
aren't as brown
as this one breakfast is almost complete
all right i am finally sitting down
having made my pancake i also plated it
up a little bit
this is what i have so we have the
smoothie over here which is a gorgeous
orange and then over here
there's the pancake that i've kind of
tried to plate it up nicely
so this is actually pumpkin puree and
honey
this is blood orange that i thought
would be a nice touch on top
and then these are golden berries i love
how this turned out i normally love
ordering things like this at breakfast
places so
that's kind of where i drew my
inspiration also you can't see it on
here because i covered it with the blood
orange
but i actually put a layer of pumpkin
butter underneath
these pancakes also smell very very nice
it just smells so like cinnamony
and pumpkiny all right gonna go for it
there's definitely a lot of pumpkin in
there
but there's a tartness that i actually
think is coming from the orange juice
that was a little unorthodox i don't
think people normally put orange juice
in their pancakes the flavor
after a while though ties in together so
it's a little more sour
but not in a bad way it almost reminds
me of like mochi pancakes this is like
pumpkin orange mochi pancakes if i eat
it with the pumpkin puree
it's pretty good i just feel like it's a
very like harvest to fall
themed um breakfast i will say though
that this is
extremely filling can't go wrong with
smoothies i really think especially when
there's so much like
sweet fruits in there like the mango and
the papaya
also i just love this color this is a
pretty big breakfast though i would say
it almost feels more like a brunch
i think it's going to take you some time
to work through it i will see you guys
again
later for lunch alvin came by to drop
off the pasta sauce thanks alvin
alright so alvin just dropped off this
sauce this pasta sauce
that smells really really amazing which
i'm not surprised by
it's alvin i gave him the butternut
squash i bought earlier
and he transformed it into this creamy
sweet and savory sauce
that has like a really wonderful nutty
flavor but that also means that for
lunch today
i am most likely gonna go with some sort
of pasta
here's what i have there's a lot of
orange going on here
three types of ravioli i did go a little
crazy butternut squash ravioli honey
roasted
pumpkin ravioli and also lobster
ravioli which sounds super bougie
butternut squash
sweet potato cauliflower and orange
pepper
alvin's pasta sauce and then there's
some shrimp i actually also have some
salmon roe here which i think
could be nice to just top it off i don't
know how the flavors are gonna blend
together
who knows a lot of this is really just
about experimenting
so basically what i'm thinking it's
going to be pretty straightforward we're
going to have a ravioli
pasta dish and then roasted vegetables
on the side
with like shrimp to top it off and just
make it into a nice meal so first things
first
i am going to roast up these vegetables
i'm just going to combine all my
vegetables into this bowl
super super orange even though this is
already such a bright orange color
i was thinking for flavoring apart from
just like your usual salt and pepper
i'm going to add in these two powders
one is red curry powder
one is turmeric there we go drizzle of
oil so now i'm just going to toss it
together
there we go spread it out it is looking
so orange let me show you
look at that this looks oddly satisfying
all right so now i'm just going to take
this to the oven
this is the vegetables are in the oven
i'm going to give it a few minutes
before we get started on the ravioli
all right it's starting to smell really
good in here i can smell the curry
coming from the oven
for the vegetables i am going to start
cooking our ravioli it
is such a beautiful color the best part
is when i'm looking at the ingredients
list for
all three of these there is no
artificial coloring and it's such a
vibrant color so the only tricky thing
is that these all have different cooking
times so i'm gonna have to cook them one
by one
all right so ravioli is looking pretty
good
there really is that variety of color
going on
i love it and then over here i'm
reheating the
pasta sauce so now it is about time that
i combine the two i'm just gonna
toss the ravioli in here turn up the
heat
i'm just gonna gently coat them in this
sauce so i'm pretty much just going to
cook this down
until the sauce reduces into a thicker
consistency but over here
my vegetables are out of the oven so i
think we're pretty close to being able
to plate this
i just need to fry up my shrimp and then
lunch should be just about done all
right it is done
it actually looks i don't know it just
looks so much fancier than i expected it
to be but
here's my finished pasta look at that
i'm very excited because there's like
vegetables in here there's pasta
there's like shrimp and salmon roll i
literally jam-packed this with
a lot of things there's also a lot of
different i think seasonings going on
because there's the curry butternut
squash pasta that has like a sweeter
taste
turmeric and that umami fishy-ness from
the salmon roll
and also the lobster and the shrimps so
this is kind of decadent i will say
can't forget my drink i have a carrot
juice here
look at this vibrant color wow
i am gonna dig in now so i try not to
cover the pattern here
too much because it's so pretty look at
this filling
same thing for this one the pumpkin one
is a
it's like a generic pumpkin color i
would say i'm trying the lobster one
first
honestly even without the sauce the
lobster filling already has
a lot of flavor let's try this butternut
squash one
it's like butternut squash pasta and
butternut squash
sauce butternut squash overload
oh that's good it's like something about
like fall spices i think
it's like kind of cinnamony there's like
a little bit of nuttiness going on
all right so i'm going to try this
pumpkin one as well here we go
pumpkin ravioli and orange cauliflower
so at first i wasn't sure about the
curry part of this but
and hear me out it actually kind of
works there's just enough curry powder
that i think
i don't know it just blends together
with that like nuttiness i was talking
about
i'm like genuinely surprised also going
to try this shrimp that i just
very simply pan fried again with some
curry and enjoy that with the pepper
and all about salmon roll all right so
the salmon roll part might be a little
crazy but i also personally just love
salmon rolls so
i don't mind adding it to it it has like
that little burst of umami flavor
i will say i also have to credit a lot
to this pasta sauce thank you alvin
i would not mind eating this every day i
mean i will say it is a little bit
extravagant there are three types of
ravioli in here after all but
for a plate that is so orange
i'm really surprised that all the
flavors
kind of work together alright so i am
going to finish up my meal now
but i will have a snack session no
matter what god i keep my energy up so
i'll check in with you guys later
all right friends it is around 3 p.m ish
right now and my friend
just dropped off this beautiful savory
squash tart from one of my
favorite bakeries here i'm to cut up a
slice for myself
here we go all right i'm just going to
go right for it
squash is so tender like when you roast
squash it's like
just a natural creaminess wow this is
exactly the kind of energy i needed for
the rest of today
i am going to savor the rest of this
bite
and then get back to work see you later
for dinner work just ended and
i am ready to get started on dinner
here's what we have for ingredients
so for this meal i only have a few
things i have this risotto
it is made with pumpkin and also
amaretti
i'm assuming this is going to be on the
sweeter side but i might be wrong
i guess this one's more of a yellowish
orange then next up i have this pumpkin
bisque
half a pumpkin here and then i have the
golden berries that we saw briefly in
the morning and then i also have some
chili oil so once again i may be doing
an unusual combination where i'm going
to be adding chili oil
i guess it's kind of like fusion-ish and
i mean chili oil
is very orange i also have this bag of
tortilla chips this is really cool
because the chips are actually colored
with things like tomato powder
carrot powder and pumpkin powder i think
i might use this to plate it up later
going back to the dish i am thinking of
using this half of a pumpkin
as a bowl kind of ambitious maybe i am
going to pretty much just scoop
out the seeds and then wrap this up in
foil and toss it in the oven
all right and now that the pumpkin has
been roasting for a little bit i'm gonna
get started
on the risotto mix and i'm pretty much
just going to stir this
until it's brown there's like a good bit
of pumpkin
in here so that's really nice i'm just
going to gradually add
water until it becomes fully cooked
i'm going to see if i can add a little
bit of this
along with the water to hopefully add to
the color
um as well as the flavor again not
really sure if this is going to work out
so it's been around 15 minutes i've
pretty much just been gradually adding
water
into the risotto mix as well as some of
the pumpkin bisque
and this is what it looks like now
there's like a nice consistency
i've also taken out my pumpkin half
and this is what it looks like now a
hollowed out
little bowl so then the next step now is
to take my risotto
and put it in here all right it is
coming together
i have my little pumpkin bowl i am going
to
very quickly drizzle on this chili oil
on top
pretty much what's left is to just plate
up the rest
of this dish and then dinner will be
served
all right and it is done i can finally
sit down
and this is dinner for today
look at that you can see the golden
berries on top
the risotto the pumpkin and the tortilla
chips at the bottom
he looks pretty good right honestly this
idea could be great for like
if you have some sort of chip dipping in
the middle maybe like an orange themed
one
let's dig in
there's definitely some fusion going on
here it's definitely like
savory in the sense of like um the onion
and the garlic which i think was already
in the risotto mix
so i'm gonna scoop up some of that
pumpkin
it's like super pumpkiny which makes
sense but the texture of the pumpkin
because it's been roasted in the oven
for a while it's
so soft it adds to the creaminess of the
dish
now this is me thinking like can you
imagine this but with like pumpkin
bisque in the middle or pumpkin soup oh
that would be so good
so the chili oil does obviously have a
kick to it so it almost
changes the dish completely into
something else it's not a bad
thing it makes the two bites i had taste
like two completely different meals
also i forgot to say that i have my
mango passion fruit tea here
it is very orange right it's like
different shades of orange going on in
there
i'm just gonna take my time and slowly
make my way through this
and then once i clean up and have a
little more stomach space
we can finally end with dessert all
right it is pretty late now
and i'm actually not that hungry anymore
i'm also i think experiencing pumpkin
fatigue originally i wanted to get
pumpkin pie but then i was like
no so in this place for dessert i am
just ending today with this
frozen persimmon super interesting i'm
wondering if it's some sort of sorbet
situation
so it is pretty much just the fruit
itself and
oh my god maybe i shouldn't have taken
such a big bite but this is really
really pleasant
honestly kind of a perfect light
refreshing way to
end today i think doing orange food
during this time of year is honestly a
great
fun challenge mainly because there's so
many seasonal items that fit under the
category
and i think that's why i ended up being
able to find a lot of things but yeah i
had a lot of fun
putting together these recipes and i
think at this point there's really only
one
color left white foods unless you guys
have something else
but otherwise i will see you guys then
you